WE HAVE THE EVIDENCE TONIGHT.
IF WE THAT AND SO MUCH MORE IN
TONIGHT'S BREAKING NEWS, AND
IT'S A BIG BREAKING NEWS NIGHT,
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: TONIGHT WE START WITH
PROOF THE DEEP STATE OF ISRAEL
IN AMERICA AND THAT YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, SEE WHAT IS
REALLY GOING ON.
PAY ATTENTION TO THIS POLL.
ACCORDING TO A BRAND-NEW
MONUMENT POLL, 74% OF YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, SAVE THIS GROUP
OF UNELECTED BUREAUCRATS ARE
SECRETLY TRYING TO MANIPULATE
POLICY, AND IT'S DEEPER THAN
THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A TON OF
EXAMPLES THAT PROVE THAT YOU
ARE, IN FACT, RIGHT.
WE WILL START WITH A PROTECTABLE
FAKE NEWS ATTACK FROM LIBERALS
AND THE DESTROY-TRUMP MEDIA.
THEY ARE TRYING TO CLAIM THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP FIRED FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR ANDREW McCABE.
OKAY.
NUMBER ONE, THEY ARE NOT ONLY
IDIOTS, BUT GUESS WHAT, THEY
ACTUALLY MAY EVEN BELIEVE THEIR
OWN LIVES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID NOT FIRE
FORMER DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI ANDREW McCABE.
THE FBI FIRED ANDREW McCABE
BASED ON THEIR INVESTIGATION AND
OF COURSE INFORMATION FROM THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT THAT
WE KNOW WILL BE FORTHCOMING.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS LOOK AT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS' STATEMENT, WHICH
THAT IS SO OVERPAID IN WAYS HE
DID NOT DO.
SESSIONS EXPLAINS THAT AFTER A
VERY EXTENSIVE INVESTIGATION
THAT THE DOJ INSPECTOR GENERAL
PROVIDED ITS REPORT TO THE FBI'S
OFFICE OF PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND THEN "THE
FBI'S OPR THEN REVIEWED THE
REPORT, AND UNDERLYING
DOCUMENTS, AND ISSUED A
DISCIPLINARY PROPOSAL
RECOMMENDING THE DISMISSAL OF
ANDREW McCABE."
BOTH THE OIG, THE FBI OPR, THE
REPORT CONCLUDED THAT HE HAD AN
UNAUTHORIZED DISCLOSURE TO THE
LIBERAL NEWS MEDIA AND THAT, PAY
ATTENTION, HE LACKED CANDOR,
INCLUDING CANDOR UNDER OATH ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS.
THAT'S CALLED LYING TO THE FBI.
THE FBI AND THE DOJ
INSPECTOR GENERAL DETERMINED
McCABE LIED ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS, THAT IN AND OF ITSELF
CAN BE A CRIME.
McCABE CAN ONLY BLAME HIMSELF,
AND BY THE WAY, WHAT CANNOT BE
UNDERSTATED IS HOW SIGNIFICANT
THIS MOVE IS.
FOR THE FBI AND THE DOJ TO
RECOMMEND THAT HE BE FIRED, IT
MEANS THAT HE DID RADICALLY
WRONG AT THE FBI.
IN FACT, SOURCES ARE TELLING US
TONIGHT, AGAIN, THAT McCABE IN
THE FUTURE COULD BE FACING
MULTIPLE CHARGES.
IT'S THAT SERIOUS.
I KNOW THE MEDIA IS NOT TELLING
YOU THAT.
McCABE DESERVES TO BE SHOWN
THE DOOR AND WE ARE ALSO
LEARNING TONIGHT THAT JUST LIKE
JAMES COMEY, McCABE HAD MEMOS
OF HIS INTERACTIONS WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE MEMOS,
THEY JUST REEKED OF DESPERATION.
REMEMBER SUSAN RICE, JAMES
COMEY, THEY ALL KEPT MEMOS.
IN REISS' CASE, TWO WEEKS AFTER
MEETING WITH OBAMA, COMEY,
OTHERS, SHE EMAILS HERSELF JUST
MINUTES AFTER DONALD TRUMP
BECOMES THE PRESIDENT.
OBAMA SAYS DO EVERYTHING BY THE
BOOK.
PRESIDENT OBAMA SAYS DO
EVERYTHING BY THE BOOK.
THE ONLY REASON RICE WAS DOING
THAT, THAT WAS A CYA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP REACTED TO ALL
OF THIS NEWS ABOUT McCABE
BLASTING THE CORRUPT MEDIA'S
COVERAGE.
HE WROTE ON TWITTER THE FAKE
NEWS IS BESIDE THEMSELVES THAT
McCABE WAS CAUGHT, CALLED OUT
AND FIRED.
HOW MANY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS WERE GIVEN TO
McCABE'S WIFE IN A CAMPAIGN BY
CROOKED HILLARY FRIEND TERRY
McAULIFFE WHO ALSO WAS UNDER
INVESTIGATION?
HOW MANY LIES, HOW MANY LEAKS
AND COMEY KNEW IT ALL AND MUCH
MORE!
PRESIDENT IS 100% RIGHT.
IF THE MEDIA HAD THEIR WAY,
McCABE, AN ACCUSED LIAR AND
POTENTIAL LAWBREAKER, WOULD
STILL HAVE THE NUMBER TWO JOB AT
THE FBI.
MOST FBI PEOPLE I KNOW DON'T
WANT HIM TO HAVE THAT JOB.
THE MEDIA DOES NOT CARE ABOUT
THE FACTS LIKE MCCABE'S WIFE,
JILL.
SHE GOT OVER $700,000, AN
OBSCENE AMOUNT OF CAMPAIGN MONEY
FROM CLINTON BFF TERRY
McAULIFFE AND ANOTHER
DEMOCRATIC GROUP FOR A FAILED
VIRGINIA STATE SENATE RUN.
McCABE EVENTUALLY ENDED UP
RECUSING HIMSELF FROM THE
CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION
BECAUSE OF ALL OF THIS, BUT ONLY
ONE WEEK BEFORE THE ELECTION IN
2016.
THEN THERE'S THE FACT ACCORDING
TO "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
McCABE WAITED A MONTH TO
NOTIFY CONGRESS THAT THOUSANDS
OF EMAILS WERE FOUND ON
ANTHONY WEINER'S LAPTOP.
McCABE, HE IS TOTALLY SHADY
DEEP STATE ACTORS AND McCABE
GOT CAUGHT RED-HANDED AND IT
LOOKS LIKE McCABE IS STILL
GOING TO END UP GETTING SOME OF
HIS PENSION, DESPITE OF REPORTS
TO THE CONTRARY.
THE LEFT IN THIS COUNTRY, THEY
ARE RUSHING TO OFFER DEMOCRATS,
RUSHING TO OFFER McCABE ALL
SORTS OF VARIOUS JOBS.
THE REASON FOR McCABE BEING
FIRED IS SO OBVIOUS THAT EVEN
LEADING TRUMP-HATER HIMSELF,
SOON TO BE MSNBC CONSPIRACY
THEORIST, CONGRESSMAN ADAM
SCHIFF IS KIND OF ADMITTING THAT
WE ARE RIGHT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ON ANDREW McCABE, DOES THE
FACT THAT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
DID SAY, DID FIND THAT HE LACKED
CANDOR AND SOME OF HIS RESPONSES
AND THAT HIS FIRING WAS
RECOMMENDED BY CAREER FBI
OFFICIAL, DOES THAT GIVE YOU
PAUSE AND DOES IT SUGGEST THAT
IN FACT HIS FIRING WAS OR MAY BE
JUSTIFIED?
>> HIS FIRING MAY BE JUSTIFIED.
THERE'S NO WAY FOR US TO KNOW AT
THIS POINT, BUT EVEN THOUGH IT
MAY HAVE BEEN JUSTIFIED, IT CAN
ALSO BE TAINTED.
>> Sean: MY BET IS HE KNOWS
IT'S JUSTIFIED.
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE HE KIND OF
MALFUNCTIONS AND SLIPS OUT OF
HIS DESTROY-TRUMP DEFAULT
SETTING AND ACTUALLY TELLS THE
TRUTH.
THIS WAS ONE OF THOSE SQUARE
INCHES AND STILL MAKE INSTANCES.
OF THE DEEP STATE, WEREN'T SO
ACCEPTING OF REALITY.
HE SUPPOSED TO WORK FOR YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE'S CAUGHT UP IN SEVERAL OF THE
SCANDALS, BUT HE'S OUT THERE
TWEETING AS ARROGANTLY AS JAMES
COMEY.
THE FULL EXTENT OF YOUR
BANALITY, MORAL TURPITUDE AND
POLITICAL CORRUPTION BECOMES
KNOWN, YOU WILL TAKE YOUR
RIGHTFUL PLACE, TALKING ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP, AS A DISGRACED
DEMAGOGUE AND THE COST BIT OF
HISTORY.
YOU MAY SCAPEGOAT AND A
McCABE, BUT YOU WILL NOT
DESTROY AMERICA.
AMERICA WILL TRIUMPH OVER YOU.
REALLY?
THIS COMING FROM BRENDAN?
ONCE VOTED FOR THE COMMUNIST
PARTY, THE CANDIDATE FROM THE
COMMUNIST PARTY RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT?
MR. PRESIDENT, I LOOK FORWARD TO
LEARNING ABOUT WHAT YOU KNEW AND
WHEN YOU KNEW IT ON A VARIETY OF
ISSUES AND I HAVE A FUNNY
FEELING WE WILL BE HEARING A LOT
MORE ABOUT YOU IN THE FUTURE.
YOU WERE SUPPOSED TO,
MR. BRENNAN, SERVED THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, NOT HER SELFISH DEEP
STATE AGENDA.
AND AS FOR ANDREW McCABE,
AFTER BEING FIRED HE ISSUED A
STATEMENT THAT IS CREATING WHAT
IS NOTHING SHORT FOR A LEGAL
NIGHTMARE, FOR HIS BFF, HIS BODY
JAMES COMEY.
HE WRITES IN PART "THE OIG
INVESTIGATION IS FOCUSED ON
INFORMATION I CHOSE TO SHARE
WITH THE REPORTER THROUGH MY
PUBLIC AFFAIRS OFFICER AND A
LEGAL COUNSELOR AS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR.
I WAS ONE OF ONLY A FEW PEOPLE
WHO HAD THE AUTHORITY TO DO
THAT.
IT WAS NOT A SECRET.
IT TOOK PLACE OVER SEVERAL DAYS
AND OTHERS, INCLUDING THE
DIRECTOR.
THAT WOULD BE COMEY -- WERE
AWARE OF THIS REACTION.
IT WAS A TYPE OF EXCHANGE WITH
THE MEDIA THAT THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OVERSEES SEVERAL TIMES
PER WEEK.
IN FACT, IT WAS THE SAME TYPE OF
WORK THAT I CONTINUE TO DO UNDER
DIRECTOR WAS TO FOR AT HIS
REQUEST.
McCABE IS ACTUALLY ADMITTING
THAT COMEY KNEW HE WAS ENGAGING
IN A MEDIA LEAK, WHICH IS THE
REASON WHY HE GOT FIRED, OR PART
OF THE REASON ON TOP OF LYING
UNDER OATH.
IT SOUNDS LIKE McCABE EITHER
SLIPPED UP OR IS THROWING HIS
BEST FRIEND, JAMES COMEY, UNDER
THE BUS BECAUSE BACK IN 2017 AND
MAY, COMEY GAVE A VERY DIFFERENT
ANSWER ABOUT LEAKS TO CONGRESS
WHILE JAMES COMEY WAS UNDER
OATH.
IF SO WHO IS JAMES COMEY OR
McCABE SAYING THIS?
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
VIDEOTAPE.
>> DIRECTOR COMEY, HAVE YOU EVER
BEEN AN ANONYMOUS SOURCE IN NEWS
REPORTS ABOUT MATTERS RELATING
TO THE TRUMP INVESTIGATION OR
THE CLINTON INVESTIGATION?
>> NEVER.
>> QUESTION TWO, RELATIVELY
RELATED.
HAVE YOU EVER AUTHORIZED SOMEONE
ELSE AT THE FBI TO BE AN
ANONYMOUS SOURCE IN NEWS REPORTS
ABOUT THE TRUMP INVESTIGATION OR
THE CLINTON INVESTIGATION?
>> NO.
>> Sean: NO.
OKAY, WITH EVIDENCE LIKE THAT
COMING OUT YOU WOULD THINK THAT
COMEY WANTED TO KEEP HIS BIG
MOUTH SHUT, BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT
HE'S DOING.
INSTEAD YOU GOT COMEY OUT THERE
ON TWITTER, HE'S TAUNTING THE
PRESIDENT AHEAD OF HIS BIG
LIBERAL MEDIA BOOK TOUR BLITZ.
TWEETING OUT "MR. PRESIDENT, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL HEAR MY
STORY VERY SOON AS THEY CAN
JUDGE FOR THEMSELVES WHO IS
HONORABLE AND WHO IS NOT."
JAMES, LIKE WE'VE BEEN SAYING,
MR. COMEY, YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO
REMAIN SILENT.
I DON'T KNOW WHO YOUR ATTORNEY
IS.
SINCE YOU ARE INTERESTED IN
AUDITIONING TO BECOME THE NEXT
LIBERAL MEDIA DARLING BY GOING
ON THE VIEW AND GOING ON WITH
COLBERT AND SITTING DOWN WITH
QUENTIN SYCOPHANT GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS, WE HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS FOR YOU.
MR. COMEY, YOU ARE MORE THAN
WELCOME TO COME ON THE SHOW,
SHARE WHAT YOU CLAIM IS YOUR
INSPIRING STORY.
I WILL GIVE YOU THE ENTIRE HOUR
RIGHT HERE ON THIS SET.
I WILL GIVE YOU THREE HOURS ON
MY NATIONALLY SYNDICATED RADIO
SHOW.
I'M ON 575 STATIONS.
COME ON!
FOUR SOLID HOURS.
YOU WANT TO GET THE TRUTH OUT,
YOU WANT TO BE OUR GUEST AND
ANSWER A FEW QUESTIONS?
, COME ON,
YOU ARE WELCOME.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHAT DID YOU KNOW
ABOUT ANDREW McCABE'S LEAKS
AND ANDREW McCABE'S LYING
UNDER OATH.
WHY DID YOU TELL PRESIDENT TRUMP
THAT CLINTON, THAT BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR DOSSIER WAS BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR
WHY DID YOU SAY THAT AN
UNVERIFIED MEETING AT
TRUMP TOWER, BUT THREE MONTHS
EARLIER IN OCTOBER OF 2016 YOU
WERE USING THAT SAME DOSSIER TO
GET A WARRANT TO SPY ON CARTER
PAGE AND THAT WAS THE BULK OF
THE FISA APPLICATION?
MR. COMEY, COME ON THE SHOW AND
TELL US WHY THE FBI ALSO NEVER
CORROBORATED OR VERIFIED THE
DOSSIER.
AND DID YOU KNOW IT USED CURRENT
AND FORMER RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
SOURCES?
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE A BIG DEAL.
DID THE FBI MAKE ANY ATTEMPT,
DID YOU MAKE ANY ATTEMPT, TO
LOOK AT CHRISTOPHER STEELES
RUSSIAN SOURCES AND INTERVIEW
THEM YOURSELF?
DID ANYONE AT THE FBI ASK HIM
ABOUT HIS SOURCES?
DID YOU PAY CHRISTOPHER STEELES?
IS THERE REPORTS THAT YOU DID
PAY THEM?
WHAT ABOUT FUSION GPS?
DID YOU EVER ASK GLENN SIMPSON
OR ANYONE AT THE COMPANY IF THEY
EVER TRIED TO VERIFY THE
DOSSIER, BECAUSE THE ANSWER IS
NO, THEY DIDN'T.
BY THE WAY, THEN THERE'S THE
FIRE SUPPORT.
MR. COMEY, PERSONALLY YOU WERE
AWARE OF COURSE THAT THE FISA
JUDGES, DID YOU NOT KNOW THAT
THEY WERE LIED TO?
DID YOU NOT KNOW THEY WERE NEVER
TOLD THAT HILLARY CLINTON HAD
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR THE
UNVERIFIED RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA
DOSSIER?
WERE YOU AT ALL AWARE THAT THE
BULK OF THE FISA APPLICATION
BEING MADE UP OF THOSE RUSSIAN
LIES?
OR HOW ABOUT ANDREW McCABE
SAYING WITHOUT THE DOSSIER IT
WOULD NOT HAVE EVEN BEEN A FISA
APPLICATION?
DID YOU KNOW THAT AS WELL?
YOU ARE RIGHT.
WITH ANDREW, YOU WERE HIS BOSS.
WERE YOU ALSO AWARE THAT CLINTON
PAID HER MONEY THROUGH HER
CAMPAIGN FOR THESE RUSSIAN LIES
AND CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN, THE DNC,
THEY FUNNELED OVER $12 MILLION
THROUGH A LAW FIRM, DID YOU KNOW
THAT TOO?
WHY DID THEY FUNNELED THAT
MONEY?
AND THEN THERE'S THE CLINTON
EMAIL INVESTIGATION, MR. COMEY.
SIT DOWN AND EXPLAIN WHY ANY
INVESTIGATOR -- WHILE REWRITING
AND EXONERATION MONTHS BEFORE
INTERVIEWING NOT ONLY
HILLARY CLINTON, BUT 17 OTHER
KEY WITNESSES?
IF THAT'S WHAT YOU DID IN THE
HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
TAKE A LOOK, MR. COMEY AT THE
SIGHT OF YOUR SCREEN.
YOU'RE PROBABLY FAMILIAR WITH 18
USC 1793.
THAT MAKES IT ILLEGAL, IN OTHER
WORDS, AGAINST THE LAW, TO
MISHANDLE CLASSIFY, TOP-SECRET
PROGRAM INFORMATION.
DID HILLARY CLINTON MISHANDLE
ALL THAT INFORMATION BY KEEPING
THAT UNSECURE SERVER IN THE
BATHROOM OF A MOM-AND-POP SHOP,
POP SHOP CLOSET?
WAS SHE TRYING TO CIRCUMVENT
CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT?
YOU ORIGINALLY SAID IT WAS
LIKELY THAT HOSTILE FOREIGN
ACTORS HACKED INTO HILLARY'S
SERVER.
DID RUSSIA HACK INTO THAT
SERVER?
TO CHINA, DID IRAN COMMITTED
NORTH KOREA?
TO DATE GAIN ACCESS TO AMERICA'S
TOP SECRETS IN HILLARY'S EMAILS?
OR WHAT ABOUT THE FACT THAT
HILLARY CLINTON, SHE DELETED
33,000 SUBPOENAED EMAILS?
MR. COMEY, IS THAT A CRIME?
IS THAT OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE?
WE WOULD LIKE FOR YOU TO EXPLAIN
A COUPLE OF THESE REPORTS.
TAKE A LOOK AT THESE HEADLINES.
OCTOBER 2016.
FBI SOURCE, MAJORITY OF STAFF ON
CLINTON KAYS WANTED HER
PROSECUTED.
EXCLUSIVE, FBI AGENTS SAY COMEY,
THAT WOULD BE YOU, STOOD IN THE
WAY OF THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
MR. COMEY, CAN YOU PLEASE
EXPLAIN THOSE HEADLINES?
CAN WE TALK TO THE AGENTS THAT
WORK FOR YOU?
THAT WORKED ON THAT CASE?
WHAT ABOUT WHAT FORMER FBI
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR IS SAYING TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT ALL OF
THIS?
YOU MAY WANT TO PAY ATTENTION.
>> I THINK WE HAVE AMPLE FACTS
REVEALED TO US DURING THIS LAST
YEAR AND A HALF THAT HIGH
RANKING PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE
GOVERNMENT, NOT JUST THE FBI,
HIGH-RANKING PEOPLE, HAD A FLAT
TO NOT HAVE HILLARY CLINTON, YOU
KNOW, INDICTED SO THAT SHE COULD
REMAIN A FLAWED CANDIDATE THAT
SHE WAS, WHICH IN MY VIEW WAS
STUPIDITY.
AND THEY ALSO HAD -- EVEN THIS
GUY TALKED ABOUT THIS.
THEY HAD A BACKUP PLAN TO
BASICALLY FRAME DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON.
THIS WHOLE THING, IN MY VIEW IS
JUST TOTAL PHONY.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL IF SOMEONE
OUT THERE IN AMERICA, SOMEONE
WHO JUST HAD A PHONY SCHEME
ABOUT YOU AND ONE ON FOR MONTHS
AND MONTHS AND MONTHS?
>> Sean: MR. COMEY, MR. DEEP
STATE, HERE'S AN OPEN INVITATION
FOR YOU TO COME ON THE SHOW.
COME TELL YOUR STORY, COME SELL
YOUR BOOK AND ANSWER SOME REAL
QUESTIONS.
AND MR. COMEY, IF YOU CARE ABOUT
THE TRUTH, IT'S FINE.
GO RUNNING TO YOUR LIBERAL
FRIENDS FOR A LITTLE SAFE SPACE
TO TALK, BUT ANSWER REAL
QUESTIONS HERE.
ALSO TONIGHT, MEMBERS OF THE
FAKE NEWS MEDIA, THEY HAVE LOST
THEIR MINDS YET AGAIN OVER ALL
THINGS DONALD TRUMP AND IN THIS
CASE FOR DONALD TRUMP DARING TO
CALL OUT THE EXTREME AND ABUSIVE
BIAS, THE MASS OF CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST THAT SURROUND ROBERT
MUELLER'S SPECIAL COUNSEL.
WE'VE BEEN TELLING YOU THIS FOR
A LONG TIME.
THE MEDIA JUST CAN'T STAND THE
FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
DEFENDING HIMSELF AND TELLING
THE TRUTH, NO COLLUSION, AND
EXPOSING THEIR AGENDA AND THEIR
LIES.
THE PRESIDENT OVER THE WEEKEND
TWEETED OUT THIS.
AS THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE HAS CONCLUDED, NO
COLLUSION BETWEEN RUSSIA AND THE
CRUM CAMPAIGN AS MANY ARE NOW
FINDING OUT.
HOWEVER, THERE WAS TREMENDOUS
LEAKING, LYING, CORRUPTION AT
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE FBI,
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
#DrainTheSwamp .
IF CONGRESS FOR OVER 14 MONTHS
AND SO FAR NOTHING, NO EVIDENCE
OF TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION.
MUELLER, IF YOU'VE GOT IT, COME
ON THE SHOW UNTIL AMERICA.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU HAVE MORE
PROOF THAT THIS IS NOT A WITCH
HUNT, OKAY, I DON'T BELIEVE YOU.
ASK EOS IS REPORTING TONIGHT
THAT ROBERT MUELLER IS MORE
INTERESTED IN WHAT HAPPENED
AFTER THE ELECTION AND BEFORE
THE ELECTION.
THIS COLLUSION, SUPPOSEDLY, WAS
THE WHOLE REASON FOR THE ENTIRE
INVESTIGATION.
BY THE WAY, HOW CAN ROD
ROSENSTEIN -- THIS GUY IS SO
CONFLICTED, HE SHOULD HAVE
RECUSED HIMSELF, BECAUSE ON THE
ONE HAND HE SIGNS OFF ON ONE OF
THE FOREGOING FISA WARRANTS
USING CLINTON'S WERE OPHTHALMIC
RUSSIAN DOSSIER, AND THAT HE
ALSO APPOINTS MUELLER.
I SAY CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
IT'S WHY THE PRESIDENT WAITED
"THE MUELLER PROBE SHOULD NEVER
HAVE BEEN STARTED AND THAT THERE
WAS NO COLLUSION AND NO CRIME.
IT IS BASED ON FRAUDULENT
ACTIVITIES AND ON FAKE, PHONY
DOSSIERS PAID FOR BY CRICKET
HILLARY IN THE DNC AND
IMPROPERLY USED IN A FISA COURT
FOR SURVEILLANCE OF MY CAMPAIGN.
WITCH HUNT!"
PEOPLE SAY THAT WE CAN ACT LIKE
YOU ARE NOT GUILTY.
OKAY, SAYING I DIDN'T DO IT
MEANS YOU ARE ACTING LIKE YOU
ARE NOT GUILTY.
THEN THE PRESIDENT ADDED, WHY
DEMOCRATS, SOME BIG CRICKET
HILLARY SUPPORTERS, ZERO
REPUBLICANS, ANOTHER DEMOCRAT
RECENTLY ADDED DOES ANYONE THINK
THIS IS FAIR?
AND YET, THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
THE PRESIDENT'S RIGHT TO BE FED
UP WITH ALL OF THIS.
LOOK AT WHAT IT HAS DONE TO THIS
COUNTRY IN THE LAST YEAR.
LOOK AT THE SIDE OF YOUR SCREEN.
MUELLER'S MERRY BAND OF
DEMOCRATIC DONORS HAVE GIVEN
OVER 50 GRAND TO DEMOCRATS,
INCLUDING OBAMA, CLINTON AND THE
DNC.
NONE OF THOSE PEOPLE DONATED TO
THE CRUM CAMPAIGN.
SO IF THE PRESIDENT IS INNOCENT,
I SAY HE HAS EVERY RIGHT TO BE
UPSET, EVERY RIGHT TO SPEAK OUT.
MUELLER'S SWAMP AND HIS DEEP
STATE, THEY ARE ABUSIVELY
BIASED.
THEY'VE BEEN SHOWN TO BE
CORRUPT, SHOWN TO HAVE AN AGENDA
AND ACCORDING TO A REPORT,
ANDREW WEISSMAN, BY THE WAY
DESCRIBED AS
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AS MUELLER
SPITBALL, ATTENDED HILLARY
CLINTON'S ELECTION NIGHT PARTY
AND LEGAL WORK FOR THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
THAT'S WAS ON MUELLER'S TEAM.
AS FOR THE MEDIA, THEY WENT
ABSOLUTELY NUTS, SPECULATING
THAT TRUMP WAS GOING TO FIRE
MUELLER.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SAID.
HE SAID IT NEVER SHOULD HAVE
STARTED.
HE NEVER INSINUATED IN ANY WAY
HE WAS GOING TO FIRE MUELLER,
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU'RE LYING
NEWS MEDIA REPORTED THIS WEEKEND
NEWS MEDIA REPORTED THIS WEEKEN
WEEKEND.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP, SHARPENING
HIS ATTACKS, REALLY TAKING IN
DIRECTLY FOR THE FIRST TIME AS
SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER,
CALLING HIM OUT BY NAME.
OF COURSE ALL OF THAT RAISES A
LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER
THE PRESIDENT WAS TRYING TO
UNDERLINE HIS CREDIBILITY, MOVED
TO HAVE HIM FIRED.
>> BIG PLAYERS IN THIS
INVESTIGATION COVERING THIS
ATTACKING PERSONALLY, THE WAY HE
ACTED OVER THE WEEKEND IS A STEP
TOWARDS FIRING MUELLER.
>> DO YOU THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
LAYING THE GROUNDWORK TO FIRE
MUELLER?
>> WE SEE IN A SERIES OF TWEETS
RIGHT NOW, THE STATEMENT FROM
THE TROMPE L'OEIL OR SUGGESTING